hot breath oh well he was asking what
sort of material are corporate gigs
looking for
i've always done me i've not well if you
know anything about my stand up
i'm pretty and i'm not slamming myself
but i'm
very vanilla in a sense of i don't push
buttons i've never
i've never thought that you know my
opinion
or my nasally voice is going to change
your political
thought or i you know i've never i've
always looked at my comedy as a
distraction
sometimes people have really crappy
lives and they need a moment
where just right somebody talking about
plato as a kid right i know it's not
edgy and if you do late night sets
you're like
okay some people don't need to hear
about you know
how many times you masturbate on your
porn some people don't care
right they would rather just have so
i've always considered myself very
matchbox 20
of comedy nobody hates it no but nobody
hates it nobody loves it but you'll
vacuum to it right
so my uh corporate
things have always been the same is uh
i've always talked about like
relationships or or
you know at the time when i was married
i had more
marriage material but it was never in a
you know my
my wife or girl you know was never
they're horrible for doing this i never
made them sound dumb i made it very like
very
mutual or you know i even changed it up
to your partner and said a husband wife
girlfriend um so with corporate events
the deal is not especially now is you
just
you have to be super um super vanilla
not stop on any toes that's how it was
two months ago but you know what the
whole world just blew up
so i don't even know one is if there's
even corporate things going to be a
thing
anytime soon um
you know now i know a lot of comics are
doing like zoom meetings
for for for corporate events which just
changed it all up
um but back to what we were talking
earlier if you're a local guy and when
this all comes around let's not talk
like
nothing's ever going to be the same it's
going to be a little weird and there
might be a little thing
it's going back to be being a really
good host
because at the end of the day most
corporate events need a host
more than they need a comedian and if
you can do both
if you're really good at you know
bringing up the
vice president of marketing and you just
know how to move things along
and throw in a couple little bits before
you bring up you're gonna get a hundred
times
more work than than expecting to go out
and do a
half hour when people are eating dessert
you know
if you market yourself as a i can host
your dinner event
and make it entertaining and move it
along you make more money
like there'll be more jobs for you yeah
if that's even a thing or just get
really good at zoom
meetings and you might even crush it
even more i don't know the
everything i'm telling you applied two
months ago
yeah most of my corporate work has come
from
uh like either word of mouth or like a
gig salad service or something like that
what have you found to be the best way
to book corporate work
i you know i have great agents and
manager like stuff like that
for me it's you know my hustle yeah
my hustle has you know i haven't had the
really in building relationships with
you know
that so that i can't speak to or you
know
for me it's just i get a phone call and
they're like hey do you want to go off
and do this
and i go yeah so so was that was that an
agent who booked the fbi for you
is that how that goes down yeah my agent
said
yeah like i get you know and what where
most of my corporate bookings come from
is the relationship between the people
putting on the event
not necessarily the corporation because
what happens is corporation a
again this is prior to two months ago
and who knows what's happening but
they'll say we're doing an event it's at
this resort
we need dinner dancing
breakout sessions and an entertainer
then that person
who they hire the event person goes okay
i've worked with this comic before i've
worked with nate pagats
and then they show usually the clients a
couple comics and they pick
so there's been a couple corporate
people who
i just never been an ass like in my
green my rider you know like stuff you
need before show
mine i think doesn't have anything so
i'm less of a pain because i always
figure i'm making enough money where if
i want beef jerky or five hour energy
i'll go to 7-eleven
after the show by myself and not make
this person
who's putting on this huge multi-million
dollar event have to worry about me
and i've gotten rebooked just because
i'm not a pain in the ass
i literally sit on the speaker box and
then somebody goes
okay you're going on stage i go thank
you walk out there and i do it and i go
goodbye everybody
and then i i leave is it it's been my
play
be a good co-worker yeah that goes a
long way in this game